thank you folks
thank you very much I think I know why
here
I love the barking I'm not gonna lie I
love my love when you bark but come on
Valentine's Day is tomorrow yeah see
it's all the all the women cheering all
the men going what oh [ __ ]
and of course this is a very special
Valentine's Day because the what they're
saying is the ultimate Valentine's Day
date movie oh jeez the guts
yes fifty Shades of Grey not into S&M
sir well let me tell you yeah this is
quite a switch cuz usually on
Valentine's Day it's people who don't
have a date who are spanking it that's
the but I love this story I smell
bitters you know in the book 50 shades
of grey came out there was an uptick in
the emergency rooms for people coming in
with shall we say related injuries they
they read the book they tried to do this
[ __ ] in the book and and they're they're
expect they're bracing for an even
bigger uptick now that the movie is
coming out in fact there's a hotline now
that you can call if there's something
in your ass press one
but it's covered under Obamacare so oh
speaking of that the president Truong
always trying to sell Obamacare and you
know trying to reach the young people so
he made a this is gonna cause a lot of
outrage I can just tell on Fox News he
made a goofy video for BuzzFeed where
he's look talking to himself in the
mirror oh my god and taking selfies with
a selfie stick which is I think that's
great because that way you can act like
all the other Democrats and distance
himself from Obama no I love the selfie
stick I'll let you it let you look more
natural when you put yourself in the
picture so it's great for Bryan Williams
poor Brian Williams what a time of
transition right though Brian Williams
going on a six-month leave Tiger Woods
announced he's leaving golf David
Letterman's leaving our friend Jon
Stewart's leaving so they'll be playing
more golf and and it's gonna all switch
around a Brian Williams is going to be
the Kardashian's dad
and Bruce Jenner is gonna replace Rosie
O'Donnell on the view so that
everybody's switching chairs not me I'll
be here just doing what I do but I have
my doubts whether Brian Lee was really
will be returned to gab for six months
or ever because they keep finding other
little lies he told he seems to get shot
at constantly her a nice guy who's got
it off his job mostly he seems to always
be getting shot at always seems to be
you know when the story is breaking they
caught him they think you know saying
that he was there when the Berlin Wall
fell actually he got there the next
morning on the Space Shuttle you see
these are the kind of things but at
least he came up with a good excuse as
to why his mom worked memory was fuzzy
about the helicopter story he said the
night before he was going to Iraq there
was a party at NBC and someone handed
him a drink it was Bill Cosby
Oh bill closby two more Bill Cosby
accusers have coming up come forward
bringing the total to everyone everyone
oh yeah Boko Haram just gave him a
Lifetime Achievement Award
I am
I'll [ __ ] you with the blow what is the
boy it's Valentine's Day it's all they
love now in other scary Islamist news
the President on States President Obama
formally asked Congress this week to
grant him authority to use military
force against Isis and what a dilemma
for the Republicans you know because if
they vote for it they're agreeing with
Obama but how can they say no to war
it's like offering a redneck ride poison
I mean I call it a Sophie's Choice but
Sophie just had to decide which one of
her kids would live this is agreeing
with Obama and the weird thing about it
is the president is asking for the
authority to wage a military campaign
against Isis which he's already doing
it's like the guy who's in the middle of
[ __ ] and saying tell me that you want
it do you mean we're doing it how much
can I tell you more you're inside me now
down in Alabama they are having a big
fight have you seen this about gay
marriage the federal court down there
actually says it is legal but to prevent
that get this 28 counties in Alabama are
refusing licenses marriage licenses to
anybody that's how important this is to
the mayor traditionalist boy you got to
give them that they believe marriage did
not just anything and is defined
strictly as a union between a man and
his sister